a laparoscopic colectomy is a surgical
some or all of your large intestine your
large intestine is the final part of a
sequence of hollow organs called the
digestive tract part of your large
intestine called the colon absorbs water
from undigested food to make waste
called stool or feces which passes out
of your body at your anus
a colectomy is usually done to treat
diseases that inflame your colon such as
Crohn's disease ulcerative colitis or
diverticulitis a blockage called bowel
obstruction
colon cancer
or a damaged or injured colon
to begin a laparoscopic colectomy your
surgeon will make a small incision near
your belly button and insert a tube
called a port gas will be pumped through
the port to inflate your abdomen this
gives your surgeon more room to work
depending on the type of colectomy one
or more additional incisions may be made
then a camera and surgical instruments
will be inserted through these incisions
after finding the damaged part of your
colon your surgeon will free it from its
attachments inside your abdomen
next the damaged part of your colon will
be removed through one of the incisions
in most cases the remaining healthy ends
of the colon will be joined together
with stitches or staples
but sometimes a colostomy procedure may
be done at this point to allow time for
part of the colon to heal in this
procedure your surgeon will close one
end with sutures or staples the other
end will be attached to the outside of
your abdomen creating an opening called
a stoma
a colostomy bag will be placed over the
stoma to collect feces from your colon
in most cases a colostomy is temporary
in a later procedure the ends of the
large intestine will be reconnected
if you have any questions about
laparoscopic colectomy talk to your
health care provider